le premier ministre a dit que les
chômeurs devrait créer des entreprises
ah oui alors je me demande avec quoi à
l'assemblée nationale je me dirigeais
que par des technocrates des
intellectuels banlieue c'est la mise aux
banques
c'est ce qui est à la limite de la ville
rose qu'on a repoussés voir
on est un petit peu abandonné on voit
bien qu'on s'occupe pas des grands pas
il ya que les villes qui comptent
vous n'avez pas de transports en commun
mais ça ne vous fait rien dépenser de
l'argent pour les ans
bah je n'aurai pas de complaisance
en ouvrant en avant pour 200 250 euros
pour pas moins de gasoil se pose la
question de savoir si ça vaut le coup
d'aller travailler à supprimer sept
trains par jour sur une ligne comme
celle ci en semaine et 5 le week-end
c'est vraiment un problème d'aménagement
du territoire
la sncf ne doit pas participer à
l'accélération de la désertification
[Musique]
y'a pas de comberge a pas d'école que
vous faites vous sortez vous voyez rien
à personne
la rentrée prochaine c'est 35 bureaux de
postes qui vont être supprimés dans le
département de l'indre la grand vide
entendez les enfants jouaient dans la
cour maintenant l'entente purée 1 c'est
le silence complet c'est le désert
c'est pas toujours évident d'accord
m
france périphérique est délaissé la
france périphérique se sent méprisée par
les pouvoirs publics par les
gouvernements qui se succèdent est
aujourd'hui trop c'est trop
[Musique]